these protesters are calling for
solidarity with the victims of police
violence they've gathered in front of
the justice department in washington to
vent their anger over several recent
killings of unarmed black men by white
police
demonstrator krishna natasan says the
shooting symbolized the us's ongoing
struggle with racism
in our country we have two sets of laws
the laws have been applied in such a way
especially in local situations that are
unjust they're unfair and they're not
equal at all
at this church outside of washington not
as on meets with other activists to
prepare their next demonstration
the people meeting here are concerned
about what they see as widespread racist
attitudes among many of the country's
police forces
i believe that uh a significant change
that's going on in the country is that
people are fed up
they're tired of the injustice and
they're they're doing something about it
thousands of demonstrators are expected
to converge on washington this saturday
in a mass protest organized by civil
rights groups
i'm going to the demonstration on
saturday because black lives absolutely
matter i would like the protest to show
a unification of the united states and
the fact that we all have rights
a final show of solidarity before
saturday's protest the demonstrators
demands are simple they're calling for
justice equality this time they say
things must change
you